hey everyone it's Mike from order flows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
where I'll be talking about you know the
differences between uh aggressive
sellers aggressive buyers and passive
buyers and passive sellers
um this is a topic that comes up quite
often with uh traders that are newer to
order flow that haven't quite grasped
the concept of passive buyers and
passive Sellers and aggressive buyers
aggressive Traders so before I jump in
if you've been enjoying these videos
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and click the notification Bell so you
don't miss a new upload and if you find
today's video helpful be sure to hit the
like button leave a comment uh sharing
your biggest takeaway or question you
know I love hearing your feedback and
you know I I like creating videos
answering users or Watchers questions
about order flow your support really
does go a long way in helping me create
more videos just like this so if you're
getting value from my channel want to
see more be sure you subscribe alright
so let's go ahead and get started with
today's topic all right so today's topic
you know sort of came up from a comment
from Frita
Maya Dev 5649 and he says hey I have a
doubt left ones are bids so that number
tells us how many aggressive sellers
bought at that level so in a downtrend
sign
so it is a downtrend sign so why does it
rally up or am I missing something
um yeah it comes down to understanding
that there's
basically four types of traders in a
market okay you have passive buyers
passive sellers those are the limit
orders then you have aggressive buyers
and aggressive sellers those are
basically the market orders or traders
that are uh lifting the offer buying the
current offer or selling into the
current bid okay and again you know if
you don't understand the difference I
want to explain it but you know for a
trade to happen a Trader has to get
aggressive okay so first let's start
with a dome I think I have a dome in
here somewhere I think I stuck it behind
here this is just a basic simple uh Dome
let me just let me just make this chart
a little bit uh smaller here so it's a
little bit easier to see let me just uh
I should have done this before I started
the video but uh but anyway let's just
uh make it here so I could have
everything on one side all right so
hopefully you can see this Dome here on
the left hand side and this is the
e-minis okay so you can see there's
right in the middle is the last traded
price then you have volume on the right
hand side
and volume on the left hand side so this
volume on the right hand side this is
the offers right that are currently on
the current offer and the next best
offer
um going up every every tick and there's
volumes there these sellers up here
these are passive sellers these are
limit orders you know people that put a
limit in the market uh waiting for the
market to come to them to execute their
trade on the bottom part of this
uh price ladder this Dome is the passive
buyers okay so you can see there's 73 at
the current at the price of uh it's hard
to see the 45 28 three quarters 116 at
28 and a half 125 at 28 and a quarter
and so on these are the passive buyers
these are the passive sellers now for a
trade to happen
either someone has come in at the market
and sell at the bid or they have to come
in and buy at the offer so an aggressive
seller will sell into a passive buyer
okay
think about that okay think of it this
way
um you go to buy a house all right keep
it simple we'll call it say the house is
a half a million dollars okay and that's
what it's listed at that seller the
person trying to sell the house at five
hundred thousand dollars is the passive
seller but you know
nobody wants to pay list price right who
all want to come in because we've all
watched uh you know House Hunters and
people will go look at three houses go
eat an ice cream and put a bid in fifty
thousand dollars below the current price
and get it but um this that's not the
reality now
you know over the last few years you
know the housing market has been pretty
strong so there's a house that's for
sale for five hundred thousand dollars
but there's 20 people that want to buy
it
so what they do is they become more
aggressive and they're like oh I know
your house is offered at five hundred
thousand but I'll pay you 550
000 for that house that person that
wants to buy the house is the aggressive
buyer they're not just basically in a
sense they're sweeping the market
they're sweeping the offer at uh half a
million and buying it up at the at the
next offer 550 000. okay now if
um you know interest rates are at zero
and you know the houses were plentiful
and it's a buyer's market right then you
know the buyer would see the house
listed for 500 000 yeah I like it but
you know what I think 500 000 is a bit
Rich
um you know I'll bid 465 000. so
the current bid is at 465 the current
offers at five hundred thousand
so if that's if something's going to
happen either the buyer has to go up in
price or the seller has to go down in
price someone's going to have to get
aggressive because now you have a
passive buyer at 465 you have a passive
seller at 500 but you know maybe the the
seller's like oh geez you know I gotta
move because my jobs require me to to
live someplace else and I I'm fine you
know I could I've made you know I bought
the house for three hundred thousand now
it's worth you know 500 but I'm happy to
sell it at 465. so he'll be the
aggressive seller and go down and hit
the bid at 465. so he's selling it
to the passive buyer at 465 okay that's
sort of how you know the bid offer
concept works okay now on a footprint
chart
I I what I did here is I made the fonts
much bigger I hope you guys can see it
because I did get some comments saying
you know your resolution honestly if
you're watching this on a on a iPhone or
smartphone yeah it's going to be a bit
hard to see what you're looking at in
the footprints okay you'd have to make
the video bigger but I tried to I
increased the font size substantially so
hopefully people can see it so what we
have here on a footprint chart okay so
like right this uh let's just find this
bar right here at 8 45.
okay you can see volumes on the bid side
volumes on the offer side okay
this 195 right here is what traded when
the market was 45 33 and a half versus
um 45 33 and three quarters 24 traded at
33 and three quarters 195 traded at 33
and a half okay that doesn't mean that
there wasn't more up here at 33 and
three quarters there probably was you
know but that's all that traded there
okay so when it was in the two-way
auction 33 and a half at 33 and three
quarters
the aggressive sellers sold 195 into the
bid at 33 and a half the aggressive
buyers only bought 24 at 33 and three
quarters 33 spot 75 okay so even though
you have volume on the bid side
that is the limit okay at 33 and a half
and only 195 was sold into it okay the
was all that was bought aggressively now
if you go one tick lower 106 at 33 and a
quarter versus
um 236 at 33 and a half 106 contracts
were sold into this bid
236 were bought from this offer
okay so there's in this two-way auction
you have more aggressive buying than
aggressive selling
okay now people will say well since you
got more aggressive buying shouldn't the
market be going up
okay well that's where the understanding
the order flow comes in okay Market this
bar went down so
just because you have more that traded
on the offer unless traded on the bid
doesn't mean you have more aggressive
buyers and the market should be going up
one you have more passive sellers so one
you have more Supply in this market and
two
only 106 on the bid that traded that was
there to essentially support this market
and the market got through that okay so
there wasn't a strong bid there even
though Moore traded on the offer so what
you have essentially is a case of you
know there's probably more on the offer
so there's Supply on the offer right
think of it back to the housing
situation when there's a lot of housing
on the market there's a lot of Supply on
the market
it doesn't you know prices don't go up
right instead prices tend to drop then
you go down at the next level 119 versus
121 33 even versus 33 and a quarter okay
it's pretty evenly matched
but still you know you had
was that two more contracts traded on
the offer at 33 and a quarter versus 33
even
people say well again you know you got
more aggressive buying here and here why
isn't this Market going up
right because they're lifting the offer
for more volume well at the same time
you have more selling because it's not
able to
keep that momentum going up there's
still passive sellers there okay because
how do I know there's still more
probably more passive sellers here is
because the Market's going down the bids
are getting taken out okay 28 versus 67
there's even less bitters here at 32 and
spot 75.
okay there's only 67 traded here so I
know this Market's probably moving fast
you got an imbalance 122 against 29.
okay so now it's starting to see these
bids get cleared out and there's not a
lot of aggressive buying this is what a
sign of Supply looks like you know sort
of heavier volume coming in
a little bit less buying a little bit
less buying and then the bids start
getting taken out quite strong 20 you
know 122 161 uh 226 653 778 actually we
this is what we call an instance of
order flow sequencing right on the
order flows Trader I have it turned off
but let me turn it on here it should
show there I believe
it has set at five again this is the uh
you mean you just give it a second here
right
yeah right here
this is what we call sequencing so it's
going down
through more and more on the bid side
okay so when you see sequencing like
that you like to see Supply coming into
the market once that Supply hits the
market you see the bids getting cleared
out for more and more and more
so again sort of getting back to that
comment let me just pull it back up here
this is where you're confusing because
you're saying aggressive sellers bought
aggressive sellers never buy aggressive
sellers sell to passive buyers okay you
can't mix up buying and selling
so
left ones left sides are bids yes this
is the bids aggressive sellers are
selling into these bids
aggressive sellers are not buying
they're selling
and yes that would be a downward sign
because you say later it's a downward
sign why does it rally up okay well
you're you're conflating aggressive
selling with buying
there's aggressive buying which would be
buyers lifting the offer so for example
um let's find sort of a swing low here
okay so here's a swing low right you got
your green candle down here it's 350
against 67. it's 130 against 205. the
passive buyers are here
130 was passively bought from aggressive
sellers 350 was passively bought from
aggressive sellers 186
was bought from the passive sellers or
sorry the aggressive sellers which was
passively bought from aggressive sellers
so aggressive sellers are selling into
these bids here
okay that's what causes the market to go
down is aggressive sellers selling into
the bids which is the passive buyers
once
that aggressive selling is getting
weaker there's still passive bids here
right we can still see in the book right
there's bids at each level
right so there's passive bids you know
below this level here okay even if you
were to look at I don't know if I got a
heat map on here
I don't know if this is it yeah this is
the you know the heat map right the book
map so you can see in here right these
are the passive
bids and offers right these are the
offers these are the bids in the book
all right let me get back to my
footprint chart here
Okay so
what you have is aggressive sellers
selling into passive bids okay then you
have a aggressive buyers buying the
passive offers right buying it here
what's going to cause this Market to go
up on the dome right which will
translate into the footprint is people
buying the 72 Lots people buying the 92
Lots people buying the 103 Lots people
buying the 147
bind everything
and then the bids will start to fill in
on the bid side as the market is going
up which is what you see on a footprint
okay so again don't conflate aggressive
Sellers as buyers they're not the
aggressive sellers are selling to
passive buyers
okay that's the difference
right
so you know even though you have you
know there's always going to be
aggressive selling and aggressive buying
in a bar in a market that's going up
right that's what a two-way auction is
right it's not a one-way auction where
price only goes up right like you go to
the auction houses prices only go up
they don't start coming down the only
times they they start to go down is at
the beginning you know I guess ever been
to like uh
um an auction
you know say oh we're gonna you know
I've been to these
uh auctions at Keeneland in Kentucky for
the resources oh this is the Sun a
Northern dancer
blah blah blah we're going to start the
bidding out at fifty thousand dollars
nobody bids okay well you know he's such
a great bloodline we started out twenty
thousand Obits you know then it gets
down to we're gonna start out at one
thousand dollars and then everyone's
attracted to the market okay so once you
know that's the only time the price goes
down but once people start bidding price
starts going up but in a two-way auction
price could go up price could go down
that's sort of the dynamic of a two-way
auction versus a one-way auction right
like eBay right it's an auction site uh
now it's maybe things like buy now but
you know price all goes up because
everyone's competing with each other to
buy one item okay what causes the market
to go down all right like a Futures
Contract is there's Supply in the market
coming in often times okay but
basically understand there's basically
four types of Traders passive buyers
passive sellers aggressive buyers
aggressive sellers aggressive sellers
sell to passive buyers
aggressive buyers buy from
uh aggressive buyers buy from passive
sellers okay and that's what causes the
markets to go up and down if the
aggressive buyers overrun
the passive Sellers and price will go up
just as price will go down like here
right
if aggressive sellers are clearing out
all the bids and hitting the next bid
hitting the next bid just cleaning out
all the bids in here all right that's
what will cause the market to go down so
again I hope that clears that up for you
don't conflate aggressive sellers is
buying they're they're not it's
completely different aggressive sellers
sell to passive buyers all right
but yes the left ones
is the bid side the right one is the
offer
all right so that wraps up this video I
hope that again I hope that clears it up
I hope you find you guys that these tips
are helpful for your understanding of
order flow
let me know what you'd like me to
discuss next by leaving a comment below
so again if you enjoyed this video make
sure you hit the like button and if you
haven't already subscribe to my channel
so you don't miss any of my upcoming uh
content right so thanks again for being
a part of my order flow community and
I'll catch you guys on the next video
bye bye
foreign